listen but  i copper i have to tell you one thing  man i my edible was pretty powerful so  you and i are going to talk a little  later and i i expect some answers out of  you  did you hear what she said she said okay  as long as you sniff my ass  not her the dog all right  yeah for the record yeah copper we'll  talk later brother  all right  was that the command guys did you hear  what the command was she goes  four on the floor  i'm gonna start using that in my bedroom  with my wife  [Laughter]  four on the floor  four on the floor let's go  i would get half of that sentence out  before it was like i'm just [ __ ]  kidding  far on the oh all right fight the [ __ ]  [Music]  [Music]  you